wie bitte was jetzt los ok erst mal
tatsächlich ich werde teil einer
mars-mission ich habe sogar schon das
ticket allerdings steige ich jetzt nicht
im nächsten raum schrift zum mars noch
ist das ja nicht möglich und wenn es
möglich wird dann frühestens mit der
ersten mars mission von spacex 2024 ja
das wäre dann doch noch ein bisschen hin
aber was ist nun fakt und wie könnt ihr
auch ein ticket zum mars lösen und teil
einer mars-mission werden jetzt in
klicks und science fiction herzlich
willkommen
ja was ist da los das hier ist
tatsächlich ein ticket zum mars und zwar
um teil der nächsten mars mission zu
werden startet am 5 mai 2018 also schon
nächstes jahr und die landung auf dem
roten planeten dann schon am 26 november
2018 gestartet wird von der vandenberg
lounge zeit in kalifonien es geht um die
mars mission des insight lenders der
sich zum ersten mal mit einem vom
deutschen zentrum für luft und raumfahrt
gebauten schlagbohrer bis zu fünf meter
in den marsboden bohren wird dieser
maulwurf ist teil des hp 3 experiments
an bord dieses sieht flow and physical
properties package soll den wärmefluss
des maß messen und damit rückschlüsse
auf die entwicklung des mars ermöglichen
professor tilman spohn dazu im prinzip
sind dies zwar einfache messungen aber
in der ausführung sind sie kompliziert
ja so der leiter dieses experiments der
maulwurf des dlr wird temperatursensoren
zentimeter für zentimeter in den mars
boden bringen getestet wurde dies unter
anderem am dlr institut für
raumfahrtsysteme in einer meter hohen
mit sand gefüllten röhrenradio meter am
instrument überwacht zudem die
temperatur der oberfläche am landeplatz
aus beiden datensätzen der messungen an
der oberfläche und im inneren können die
wissenschaftler dann auf den wärmefluss
des planeten schließen zitat aus diesen
erkenntnissen lernen wir dann auch mehr
über die entwicklung unserer erde so der
professor spuren eigentlich sollte die
mission schon im märz 2016 starten doch
ein vakuum lag am ersten hauptacts prim
and dem seismometer stoppte den start
dieser schaden ist jetzt behoben so dass
die mission jetzt starten kann mit dem
seismometer sollen bei der mission mars
beben und asteroiden einschläge gemessen
werden und so auf die zusammensetzung
des mars zurück geschlossen werden
die mission soll endlich aufschluss
darüber geben ob der kern des mars fest
oder flüssig und damit auch ob er heiß
oder eher kalt ist das sensationelle der
mission ist dass die passagiere
mitnehmen kann natürlich nicht als
astronautin oder astronauten trotzdem
kann man ein solches ticket lösen und
das geht ganz einfach man geht auf die
seite der nasa den link dazu habe ich in
die video beschreibung gepackt und dort
trägt man ein paar daten
natürlich den eigenen namen ein und
schon bekommt man dieses ticket des
rätsels lösung an bord des länder sind
mikrochips auf denen die namen der
passagiere gespeichert sind ist der
insight länder also auf dem mars
gelandet gehört man also zu den ersten
menschen deren namen auf dem mars
gelandet ist schreibt mir doch mal in
die kommentare ob wir es gemacht haben
würde mich mal interessieren wie viele
von euch dann zum mars fliegen hierbei
klicks um ihr vater natürlich alles über
diese mission wenn er kein video dazu
und auch zu allen weiteren themen
verpassen wollt dann drückt mir hier ein
abo aufs auge und vergesst nicht den
genau auf die glocke ja hier geht es
weiter mit ihnen musk mars missionen
staaten 2022 das ist wirklich
sensationell also nicht verpassen und
draufklicken viel spaß dabei und
ansonsten bis dann bleibt dann